في مخيم قلنديا للاجئين شمال القدس اوقفت
قوات الاحتلال 16 فلسطينيه وقتلت سميره
اصلا وهو اب
لثمانيه ابناء كان يحاول الوصول الى نجله
رمزي الذي اعتقالته قوات الاحتلال حين
اطلق جندي رصاصه مباشره عليه وترك ينسف
حتى الموت يعني لو كان في مقاومه او كان
في ضرب حجار او اي شيء كل واحد بيحكي بس
يعني اخوي اللهم انه بس ظل عن السطح طخه
بدم بارد ولكنه طخ بني ادم
في هذه الاثناء كانت قوات الاحتلال تقتحم
البلده القديمه في نابلس حصلت حاره
الياسمين والمحاور الرئيسيه
وقبل الانسحابها اصابت سبعه فلسطينيين
بالرصاص واعتقلت مقاومه من عرين الاسود و
اربعه من رفاقه
وبعد انتهاء العمليه العسكريه لملمت
الامهات الشراح
الشعب الفلسطيني الذي يبقي مكتوف الايدي
لديه جميع الخيارات مفتوحه من اجل الدفاع
عن نفسه على المجتمع الدولي والاداره
الامريكيه التدخل السريع للجم تصرفات هذه
الحكومه
مع الاجراءات الانتقاميه السياسيه
والماليه الجديده
لكن في الفلسطينيه يخشون ان يكون هذا
العام اكثر دمويه كون الحكومه الجديده تضم
احزاب توصف بالاكثر تطرفا واستهلت مهامها
بتدليس المقدسات
والاعتقالي والقتل وفي اثني عشر يوما
اقتحم الوزير لتمار بني كفير المسجد
الاقصى ودمر مستوطنون مقابر مسيحيه وقتل
جنود الاحتلال سبعه فلسطينيين واعتقلوا
اكثر من 100 وسبعين فلسطينيه